no because i recently got back into golf
um and i was like my god that is the
most boomer thing i've ever done see i
don't i don't think golf is a boomer
thing you know i i feel like it's a
pretty much i don't think it's a
difference yeah it's a privilege
if you're broke you can't be playing
golf that's just facts that's true it's
just goldfish isn't a boomer thing golf
is just a uh you have a lot of
displacable income kind of thing i think
it's just yeah but that's the thing
right i think people a lot of people
mistake it as a boomer thing because
it's played by a lot of people of the
older generation but that's because they
have the time and the money now yeah and
also you know relatively speaking golf
doesn't really take as much of a
physical you know tax on you as like say
you know a rugby or a cricket right no
golf is fun as [ __ ] yeah i i was like
actually properly into golf when i was
younger like to the point where i
started getting like proper golf lessons
and everything like that i went to golf
camp a couple of times it was a golf
course yeah
when i was like 10 years old i like
during like summer holidays my golf cam
it's like it's literally just like think
of
you go and like you you stay over in
like a golf club
uh for like a couple of weeks yeah and
every day you just get up and you just
learn to play golf what yeah and i was i
think like 10 years old and like forget
how to do it no uh surprisingly i i kind
of remembered it uh yeah you went to a
driving range i went to a driving range
with maki and maylene um because there
was one like kind of nearby my house
yeah and um it was a really [ __ ]
fancy one like i knew this was this
wasn't like the you know the downtown
alley like you know [ __ ] we're gonna
build this driving range here because
there's nothing else around kind of
thing because it's like
you you literally got like a buggy
service from the car park to the
building see if you were far away see i
i feel like there's always like levels
of like how into how into you are you
into like golf right because like i've
never obviously i didn't come from the
most privileged families like the only
golf clubs i've ever owned were like a
pa a pair of like
a set of golf clubs that i bought in a
car boot itself like 50 bucks yeah yeah
yeah yeah you know so i've i always went
to like you know the really cheap
driving ranges and really cheap they're
really cheap of golf courses but there
was those were still fun as [ __ ] yeah
the ones i went to back in australia
were like still like obviously made in
like you know it's like 70s and like 80s
so it's like it's still very old like
you you get like a there's just like
this machine that you just like press a
button and you put a basket under it and
they just like shits out 100 golf balls
into a basket yeah and then you kind of
you know one at a time you put it on the
tee and you like whack it off this one
we went to though i don't know if all
japanese driving range is like this
because this is the first time i went to
yeah but like you walk in i'd never seen
like this many polo shirts in one
building
and it's like everyone but like
everyone's like slicked hair like really
like pristine pants and everything like
clearly like i was like oh okay we're in
like a like a nicer driving range yeah
and they like made us like make these
like membership cards that you didn't
even have to pay for you just like you
just you get you're like okay the moment
you're here you have to make a
membership card i was like okay
so then you and then you fill this thing
up like a like a credit card you put
like you put cash into it and then you
pay for the golf balls using your
membership card yeah but and so like
because i was so used to the you know
the pressing the button and then the
ball shooting out into the basket yeah
so i was like i was looking for that
machine right i was like okay where
where is it
it it wasn't there it was literally just
like it looked like a [ __ ] atm and
you'd put the card in and you'd be like
how many balls would you like and i was
like uh a hundred and it's like okay go
to this you know go to this field
it's like
where are the balls right i was like
looking around
yeah balls it's like okay whatever i'll
just go to it
there's a [ __ ] you get to it there's
no t on the green
really yeah and i'm like there's no t
there's no machine that shits out the
balls
i was like okay what do i do and there's
just like a little like you know in like
golfing uh not golfer bowling alleys
right you know there's like little
tablet that you have yeah shows the
scores there was just like that but like
a tiny one right so i was like and
there's just one button that just says
start okay and i was like okay i pressed
start the [ __ ] t and the with the
ball on top of it comes out from under
the green are you serious it just goes
what the [ __ ]
and i was like oh
and i whack it immediately the moment i
whack it the t goes down another ball
appears in its place holy [ __ ] i've been
and i was like this is the most five
head but why the [ __ ] was i wasting my
time i was playing amazing i was playing
golf like a peasant this
being an idiot looking around like
where's the where's the golf ball
[ __ ] machine
i don't know that makes golf sound hella
funny yeah that was so good and then and
then you have like a counter that shows
how many balls you have left and if you
say for example like you know you pay
for 100 balls but you know after a while
after you swing a golf club 100 times
your arms and shoulders start to get a
little bit sore yeah yeah so you're like
oh you know maybe i just want to like
call it a day after 80 balls or whatever
so you just press stop the money comes
back into your membership card and then
you can just leave [ __ ] you know that
i'm like how much is it like to do it it
was uh 2 000 yen so about 20 dollars for
120 balls that sounds fun as [ __ ] which
is honestly not bad because like it's
like i remember playing golf as a kid
and it was like
it has the image of being an old man
sport but it's like i still think golf
is boring as [ __ ] to watch right yeah
it's one it's one of those sports where
like i cry right now
it's one of those sports where i'm just
like i i like golf i i get golf it's i i
don't understand anyone the only time
i'll ever sit down willingly to watch
golf is when i find a youtube video on
my recommender which is like top 10
miracles during golf tournaments okay
i don't think playing golf is boomer i
think watching golf is boomer okay i'm
going to draw the line there i'm going
to draw the line there
um but yeah i mean like i remember i was
like actually like super super into golf
i found it like super fun because i i
wasn't really really the most athletic
kid as a kid i mean like i was like in
the basketball team but i feel i feel
like i got put into into the basketball
team just because i was tall yeah and
that was like the prerequisite yeah um
but i didn't really enjoy so much um
playing like really high-intensity
high-intensity sports yeah but then i
just really enjoyed golf because it was
more of like just a relaxing you just
hone one skill yeah and then there is
nothing more satisfying than that moment
where you just hit the ball perfectly
yeah right and you can tell you hit the
ball perfectly because like sometimes
you hit you hit the ball and it slices
or you know sometimes you sometimes
reverse to the right and then you could
just you feel it in your hands because
there's like a vibration vibration in
your hand where you when you hit it a
bit wrong but when you hit it and you
feel like it's like hitting air you know
it's like i'm hitting nothing at all
yeah it's like it's like hitting nothing
at all i've never played golf you've
never oh yeah only mini golf okay mini
golf i feel mini golf has its own we
need to go play golf yeah we need to go
play golf
we should go to the driving range near
my house because like that place was
actually like i want to go back yeah i i
did ask after that session i looked at
marky dead in the eyes and i was like
where do i go to buy a golf club
i was legit this close to just buying a
golf swing like i remember the one
moment that sold me on golf as a kid
because uh i went to the driving range
driving range is just fun because you
just [ __ ] hit a ball and you just you
don't matter it's just really satisfying
hitting a ball you know i just wanted to
yeah but like on like on like the actual
golf course is where you have to
you have to like actually think about
what you're doing you can't just like
blindly hit a ball and i remember like i
was i had an instructor at the time
and
so like on the driving range and in golf
in general so if you don't know golf
there's like a set of golf clubs and
that is numbered right so the lower the
number the like the less the sharper the
incline is the club all right no no it's
the it's less inclined or less inclined
yeah yeah so for example like like a
two iron goes almost straight right so
it's a lot harder to get the ball up and
give it like air time right
um so for me like like my comfort my
comfort zone was like a nice seven iron
that's about to say it's it's the same
the seven nine
because like on the on the driving range
if you want to feel like you can play
golf you get out the seven iron right
yeah because you can get a decent amount
of air with a seven iron like almost
guaranteed it's like a perfect 45
degrees yeah but also like a decent
amount of distance as well so you could
you could feel like yeah i can whack a
[ __ ] ball i can whack a [ __ ] ball
so like so i remember i was on this golf
course uh with this instructor right and
so
and so
how i uh and so between me
and the uh the the flag so basically the
hole
um there was like this this this hill
right yeah and uh on the hill was like a
sand trap right so i need to get i
needed to get enough air to get over the
sand trap and also
uh onto like onto the green right i feel
like i know where this is going
no and and so and so
um and so in my mind i'm like this is
two shots this is two shots right
because i need to get over the sound
trap and then another shot to get to the
green so what happens i pull out my
trusty comfort seven iron my my good old
trusty seven iron right and and um i'm
about to hit it and my golf instructor
goes no
you're not you're not using that seven
nine i've been using the seven iron for
the entire golf course and he picks out
the three iron right yeah and he goes
use this and he goes i go i can't use
that i'm not i can't get enough air i'm
gonna hit the sand trap and he goes no
you can do it i believe in you and i
just like and i just like what no no i
can't do this this is this is three
this is this isn't even a five iron this
is a three iron he goes no just do it
just trust just trust me just do it yeah
and i remember like it was it was like
it was like you know being
like when neo discovered that he was the
one in the matrix yeah yeah because i
remember hitting this ball
and i couldn't believe that it it just
like so this was the sand trap the ball
went here it went just perfectly enough
over the sand trap and it perfectly
landed on the green right and i was just
like what is this feeling
am i the chosen one what is this i know
i know like i like remember that moment
for the rest of my life because like
that was the most satisfying shot i've
ever hit in golf and from that moment on
i was like as even as a kid i was like i
can see why people play golf the only
thing that would have topped that
experience is if your golf instructor in
the wii sports voice was like nice shot
nice approach
so i mean it is a very rewarding sport
uh yeah yeah i mean like all sports are
yeah because so like when i was at the
driving range because it was [ __ ] i
don't know five six years at least
minimum since i last went to a driving
range i think i was in like high school
last time i went so obviously i was like
i knew you know basically like how to
swing and everything but i was [ __ ]
slicing that [ __ ] like crazy every
single time and i'm like man what why am
i slicing it yeah and just like it go to
the point where i was like deadpan
serious just like
slowly like just [ __ ] doing every
single movement possible being way too
serious about this [ __ ] and i was like
and at one point i remember i was like
i got it
i swung locked on yeah i locked on i was
like this is the position right here i
just have to nail this and the moment i
got it i think i nodded like it was it
because again it's like as god said it's
like when you hit that perfect straight
like perfectly angled shot yeah you just
hear the cleanest like whack sound yeah
and nothing else but when you [ __ ] up
you hear like a hit like it's like it's
like a really like [ __ ] up sound yeah
it's like it's like the best way i can
describe it it's like you know when some
f when you play some fps games and you
get that headshot right
and like a lot of a lot of like fps
games have this like really satisfying
sound when you get that hit yeah yeah i
think like golf just has that irl you
know when you get that satisfying like
perfectly like perfect shot on that golf
ball
it's like designed to have that
satisfying sound i want to go it's just
how do you
get into golf it's not like a thing that
well okay so i didn't have a i don't
have a golf set or anything um monkey
and mainly does uh but a lot of those
places like driving range and stuff like
that they give you like rentals um so
the only ones they gave me was a seven
iron because of course
is that just universal yeah
it's just like the you've never played
just use this we'll start you off with
the seven yeah so they said all they
gave me was a driver and a seven iron
right and they were uh i like happy
gilmore
you get into the run-up yeah i mean
that's a good movie yeah
um yeah and then you just like kind of
just get a feel for it after a while but
it's i think it's definitely best to go
with someone who you know knows at least
the bare minimum knows how to swing a
golfer yeah yeah my brother played a lot
of golf
company
he played like i think he did like
tournaments and stuff really yeah but i
i never did i was always more into like
stuff that was like way more active
right yeah right running or just
headbutting
[Music]
that's great i mean i mean golf is like
monkey mode but like it's controlled
monkey mode because you're just you just
you just gotta whack that that doesn't
sound very monkey motive what do you
want to try to describe golf in a way
that i like
that's not how it is you're just
whacking a ball i mean how how that's
not monkey mode no just think of no no
instead of monsters i think that's just
monkey just think of this swing like in
the wild just think of it instead of an
fps where you shoot someone in the head
it's like an fps but like the bullet is
the end of the golf stick and the ball
is the head that's such a short point
that's all it is you get the perfect
shot boom so you don't need to sell me
on golf i want to try